our next talk is by through old thousand
oh you should all be familiar with that
with the organizer grunt self and direct
the red food center
remember Center for Theoretical
neuroscience Center for Theoretical
neuroscience and I personally would like
to thank heaven for inviting me
great thanks okay so see obviously
vision is a huge huge area and I teach a
whole course on neural mechanisms of
vision and so my my goal here is to
really highlight some of the
computationally interesting open
problems that that I think people from
the company people coming from computer
science and engineering are especially
well suited to to to address so the the
four topics I'm going to try to focus in
on are the the retina in the cuz I think
this is a good example of where we
actually understand something about the
kinds of neural computations and
formatting of information that's going
on in the nervous system in terms of
engineering principles and I'll try to
highlight some of those and then I
movements which is a really sort of
interesting dynamic aspect of vision and
then talk some about cortex and really
trying to build on what I'm already
talked about this morning and then talk
about mysteries so I hope that so stay
in suspense for that okay so I guess
I'll first began by asking the question
what is vision for
so any any movement what sense angles NZ
just awesome sensing okay food food prey
finding prey yeah so it's a really
important question right and so it's uh
and it's a non-trivial question to
answer as well right and I think it's
off and times easy to come up with just
some simple answer that question you
start then probing the nervous system
and and but but before doing that I
think it's really important to sort of
think about that and one way to think
about the answer to that question
another way of asking it is why did he
why did vision evolve how did it evolve
and what do what do animals do with the
visual systems besides us right so so
how did it sort of get there and and so
there's a lot so a lot of people who
have looked at this question of
evolution VI and evolution of visual
systems in particular Dan Nielsen and
also Michael land and done a lot of work
in this area and so this is one paper by
Danielson from a while back where they
were trying to sort of estimate about
how long did it take the eye to evolve
and this is a really interesting
question because it's oftentimes people
who advocate for intelligent design they
point to the eye as an example of
something that could never you know
evolve through just sort of random kind
of permutations and so forth and and
even Charles Darwin himself was sort of
kept kept awake at night by this
question right he's as much as he liked
his own theory was like well what about
the eye you know this is how do you
explain that and so so what they did in
this paper is they just tried to come up
with a the pessimistic part is just
really a conservative a conservative
estimate for how long it would take to
to evolve an eye and what this diagram
is showing us a just how many steps it
would take incremental steps on each one
of these this is 176
of 1% each going from here to here so
there's sort of different jump many
different jumps here how many steps
would it take to go from just a set of
photoreceptors that are inserted into
the epithelium and the skin so just
having skin with some photoreceptors in
it how long would it take to go from
something like that to something like an
eye cup with a refractive material in
front of it that forms an image okay
that you could call an eye and so you
know you can sort of go into the paper
for the details of how they got into
that and how you know how many sort of
morphological changes and trying to
estimate about how many generations it
would take to bring about those
morphological changes and the answer is
about five hundred thousand years which
is remarkably short right in the
evolutionary timescale and all of this
happened about a half a billion years
ago at this time of that the Cambrian
explosion okay so the fitness function
and so this is the interesting part is
that at every incremental step along the
way you can measure an increase in
optical quality okay so there's
basically what they're trying to do is
form a better and better image and they
have a measure of that yeah for this
increase in quality to be measured by
experience in nature so in the answer is
probably a billion times more put in by
experience by in nature works for
something for something for something to
be vibrated with this it means that for
a long time right - to actually
appreciate that right that so that's the
interesting part of it is they just sort
of took optical quality here as a proxy
for behavior right but the other
interesting question is that you know as
the eye improves there's a brain sitting
behind that eye that has to appreciate
that extra thing you gave it right you
just gave it a better image the brain
needs to be hungry for that and say oh
good you know I like that please give me
more right
actually it's well of course yeah yeah
right the whole thing outside of that
but the but the point of these two these
two things had to kind of go together so
that's it you know I I don't know the
answer all right but but we should right
this is like before sort of unjust if we
tell you understand it but the neurons
are doing inside the system how can you
understand what that without knowing the
answer that question right it's it's
non-trivial question to act to answer
but an important one to to sort of
acknowledge and think about and so this
is another really nice piece of work by
Michael and just showing these these
different kind of eye designs that have
come about through evolution beginning
with a pit I here which is a simple just
just literally a chest out pit in the
skin that has photoreceptors in it that
forms a very kind of crude image some
animals still have this today like the
infrared organ of snakes uses that kind
of eye some animals have pinhole cameras
other animals use mirrors to do the
refraction so it's literally a mirror
not not not a reflecting tepee dome like
your cat's you have that just doing
amplification of light this is literally
a mirror in the back of the eye that's
bending the light multiple lens systems
the fish have these spherical lenses and
these spherical lenses have evolved
independently six or seven different
times and that's very interesting
because to build a spherical lens
there's a certain what to do it
optimally there's a certain way you have
to change the index of refraction as you
go from the center out to the perimeter
here in order to reduce aberrations and
the fish have discovered that design
independently six or seven different
times and this is all right down here so
it's really remarkable about this this
this this article in this diagram is
that if you understand optics you can
make sense of all these different eyes
and you can sort of come up with
plausible stories of how they came about
and what they're trying to do and how
they're well-suited to the animal in
that particular milieu if you didn't
know about optics you'd be host right
you just like wow you know biology is
really diverse it's messy you know it's
just all kinds of things can happen in
nature right and so I think in a similar
sense this is kind of where we are in
understanding the brain so when we
appeared in the brain there's not just
like a book we can open and say here's
the principles of information processing
that you need to understand the brains
and so we're in this kind of curious
position of having
sort of conceive of those principles at
the same time as understanding what the
nervous systems are doing and how
they're implementing those things okay
but this is a really inspiring example
because this is a case where you know
what biology is trying to do right we
have we have good theories we understand
the physical principles behind it and
biology does that okay it's not the
biology can't do it biology can do just
about anything and if you don't believe
it
read this book here so this is this is
actually it's one of the books we have
for the semester long program here in
the cyber business too
we have a bunch of books we ordered for
the library here this is one of them
this book on animal eyes by Michael
Anton Dan Dan Nielsen and after say it
was it so we did a seminar on this on
this book in the Redwood Center a few
years ago and it's very thin book it's
only about that thick right so it's kind
of deceiving it's a well I can read this
you know tonight or something it took us
an entire semester to go through the
book one chapter at a time and I sort of
by the way I sort of think about this
describe this book is that before I read
this book I thought I understood vision
and once I read this book I realized I
didn't understand anything about vision
okay it's just that makes you sort of
think about in a very completely
different way and again it's not really
about the brain it's it's a lot about
optics and the design of eyes but it
gets your thinking about how biology
works and and the kinds of things that
biology can do and and especially that
you know that when when you understand
what the principles are it all starts to
make sense okay and that's what that's
what they do in this book it's full with
physics and optics okay so with that
with that being said let's go to the
first topic which is the retina and
another really excellent piece of
reading here if you want to learn more
about retina again in terms of like
engineering principles is this wonderful
book by Robert Rodya called the first
steps of seeing and which kind of
interesting about the way he writes this
book he's a biologist but he he writes
this book calls almost like an
engineering manual but at the same time
he sort of disavows engineering right he
says well biology doesn't do engineering
don't think of it that way but then you
know he's just like that reads
beautifully like that so that's one of
the reasons why I like it so much but
but it's a really great place to start
to learn about this stuff okay so so
what is the retina so the retina sits
here at the back of the eyes this is
this very thin sort of region of that
goes all the way from here to here right
around and it contains the
photoreceptors and tons of neural
machinery that are doing computations on
the image some of which we understand
many of which we don't understand and
the result of all this information
processing that's done in the retina is
fed out here in the optic nerve so all
these fibers about 1.5 million nerve
fibers are exiting the eye and that's
our sole connection to the visual world
is everything this and this not the
optic nerve okay summary of all this
computations that done is done here okay
the way the information gets from the
photoreceptor so the photoreceptors
don't connect directly these fibers for
the most part they have to go through
all these information processing stages
in this network of neurons here so we
could just take a section of the retina
here you know and just sort of zoom in
or zoom in on it and blow it up this is
what we would see this is this is the
bat the very back of the eye here
something called the retinal pigment
epithelium where the photo pigment
molecules are regenerated these are the
photoreceptors here the rods and cones
the rods are called like rods right and
then the cones and gives the cone tips
here that sit in there so these are the
photoreceptors back here and the light
is coming in this way okay white is
coming in from top to bottom and so big
the way we're going to show some of
these diagrams and the way it's in the
book this diagram is flipped
okay so just bear that in mind so light
is coming from the bottom here and going
to the back of the eye okay so the
photoreceptors here and then there's all
these different layers of processing
here and the first is the horizontal
cells which we'll talk about the kind of
computation that they do and then the
outputs of the photoreceptors after
they've been processed by the horizontal
cells refer to these bipolar cells which
are kind of like vertical process these
through the retina which send in which
relay the information from the
photoreceptors to the retinal ganglion
cells down here and then from each
retinal ganglion cell there's a single
axon coming out and that is all these
axons together from the retinal ganglion
cells that converge you know some way
wherever here that that come out the the
optic nerve
okay and that's in that and so what the
only thing that the brain gets to hear
about or know about the visual world is
what the retinal ganglion cells tell it
okay not what the photoreceptor okay so
it's after going through all this
processing so let's talk a little bit
about the photoreceptors because again
this is kind of some sort of an
engineering feat to to do this to build
a system that can do that and so so I
just mentioned there's two different
types of photoreceptors the rods and the
cones here and as many of you know the
the the rods service in that the lower
light levels and the cones service and
the higher higher light levels so the
first remarkable thing to to know about
the system is that works over an
enormous dynamic range of light
intensities twelve orders of magnitude
okay so down here this is candelas per
meter squared the way just a physical
physical measurement of light intensity
so all the way down at 10-6 candelas per
meter square that's the threshold of
human vision this sort of lowest light
levels you can sort of say that there's
light or not light present all the way
up here to nearly ten ten to the six so
it's like snow in sunlight when you're
looking to snow that's sort of sort of
blindingly bright okay well so really I
guess 11 11 ish orders of magnitude okay
so it's huge dynamic range that we can
work order work over there's no camera
that you can build today that does that
okay that operates in those in that over
that regime it's just amazing so how
does it do it well they're the rods work
over this regime over upper one this is
just representing the pupil function so
after the the pupil diameter is a
function of light intensity and it
shrinks as tension and since the decree
increases and everything here is on a
log scale right so that's the
engineering Rohde act this is from
Murray X book okay everything is here in
this log scale so you can sort of do
multiplication is like a no slide rule
and so so you just after take candelas
per meter squared go through the pupil
that tells you the retinal ill
luminescent Rowlands and then now you
can calculate easily the the photon
catch rate for the rods and for the
cones up here so the garage work over
this range and the cones take over this
range and there's some range of between
here of light intensities where both
systems are working together okay so so
the thing that's really remarkable here
is for that where the rods work here
over this dynamic range for most of that
dynamic train
they're operating they're operating a
single photon detectors and if they
didn't if they weren't sensitive to
single photons that they could not
reliably detect single photons you would
actually be blind over this entire range
of light intensities you wouldn't be
able to see wouldn't be able to hike and
starlight or moonlight and things like
that okay so so you would be you just be
useless okay so so they have to be able
to detect reliably single photons so
what the rods do is they take a single
photon a placebo photon event and they
amplify that until 1 millivolt
hyper-polarization so one millivolt
change in the membrane potential due to
a single catching a single photon of
light yeah so because you would need
okay so thank you thanks for asking okay
I say so you have read the book as the
short answer but okay so but it's
basically because you'd have to dude if
you just sort of calculate it out then
you have to look at coincidences to get
enough light to get two photons per rod
in that regime then you would have to be
sort of way up here at a much higher
illumination level he goes to the
logical that I forget it exactly I'm
sorry but so but but the idea is that
these subs but in this regime
it's just single photon events and they
don't overlap in time okay so this is
the threshold of vision here to the
minus six Candela at the end of your
squared and that translates up to about
one photon every 5,000 seconds for a for
a rod so on a per rod basis is one
photon arriving every 5,000 seconds and
you can operate in that regime okay and
that's because there's all this pooling
happening over over rods but those but
the point is that those those events are
reliable okay those are reliably
detectable events that's the rods and
the cones are working over this range
okay so to do that it's just just for
some remarkably molecular there's a
biochemical cascade that takes place
between the photon and this
hyper-polarization event that is just
incredible so he describes it in the
book I encourage you to read about it
because your jaw will drop in terms of
the local molecular machinery that is so
that it's work to do that and it's a
really amazing
say that one photon excites multiple
rods like a single rod so so assess so
when a single rod captures a photon it
can take that single photon event and
convert it to a 1 millivolt reliably
until 1 millivolt measurable
hyper-polarization okay so so so in that
but then so many many rods are pooled
together into one bipolar cell but all
it takes is maybe even one or two of
those rods within a pooling region to
give a reliable response in the bipolar
cell okay so you don't you don't need
many photons over the entire retina to
see to say that you saw a flash of light
okay okay and so these these burdock's
and molecules that are sitting in the in
the in the rod outer segment they're
basically they're trigger-happy
molecules they're just all just waiting
for a photon to come so that's a very
tricky thing to do how do you design
something to trigger happy yet reliable
right you don't want to have false
alarms okay so that's the really that's
the difficult problem that nature had to
solve and it solved it okay then so that
so now you have all these measurements
that coming from the rods and you only
about have about 40 millivolts of
dynamic range per photoreceptor so that
is from its resting membrane potential
which is about minus 40 volts that's if
there's no light when light comes in
that x2 hyperpolarize the the membrane
potential it lowers it and the lowest it
can go is about like minus 80 or minus
90 or something like that - 80 s okay so
you only have 40 millivolts and dynamic
range from no light to maximum amount of
light that's it 40 millivolts of dynamic
range okay and so you have to take that
12 orders of magnitude dynamic range of
light intensities that we were talking
about and cram that into 40 millivolts
of dynamic range right so there has to
be a lot of dynamic gain control in
comparison adjustments going on in the
system and that's one of the things that
the horizontal cells are doing so this
horizontal cells that spread their
processes laterally they're connected by
gap junctions and so the way that you
but though that as Jeff Lichtman
mentioned that gap Junction is basically
like a direct direct resistive coupling
between neurons where electric
electrical charge can flow very quickly
between neurons without having to go
through a chemical synapse the way you
can tell they're connected by gap
junctions you inject in
a single horizontal cell here and the
whole network to which is connected
lights up so all they did in this
experiment is they injected dye here and
then lit up that neuron that neuron that
neuron there everything because the dye
just sort of spread through all this all
these networks that are connected by gap
junctions in their network so how does
that work the way it works is as follows
so here's that just showing a cone a
single cone when a few photons for a
cone that needs about 3 3 photons or
second is about as threshold for giving
reliable responses so when it gets
enough photons in here it's its membrane
voltage here hyperpolarizes at lowers
and that results in a change in
glutamate release here and that and the
turn hyperpolarizes hyperpolarizes this
horizontal cell okay and then that
horizontal cell in turn feeds back on to
the cones ok via an inhibitory mechanism
which is not entirely understood what
that is is one of the most basic
computations in the system that sort of
surrounds suppression and how it exactly
attacks the channels it's using and so
forth it's not entirely understood but
it's in general suppressive meaning that
and exerts a depolarizing influence on
these cells here so it makes that makes
it harder for them to depolarize and
respond to hyperpolarize and response to
light ok so it's a suppressive effect on
the unnies neighboring on these
neighboring cones and then because these
because these because these horizontal
cells are connected by gap junctions
this activity spreads throughout this
network over potentially over very large
distances and that in turn results in
suppression on to all these other
neighboring cones so why is the system
doing that when light falls on this
single cone it ends up suppressing the
cones around it I'm sorry contrast okay
so these are all the old-fashioned
answers that even will be intact but in
textbooks but I think the modern way
that many of us think about this is due
to the in terms of this whitening theory
that what the system is trying to do is
D correlate the signal so in natural
scenes and natural images there's tons
of correlations ok so if you just look
at this scene here this pixel is white
and the neighboring pixel is also white
white white white white white white
right that's a very inefficient way to
send an image right when you send an
image down the Internet
don't go white white white white white
okay you send differences you compute
differences and you send that you send
that information so that's sort of one
way of thinking about it this is the
theory of Jo attic and relish that they
proposed in the early 90s the retinal
whitening theory so one way of thinking
about this is this that what this
horizontal network this this cell
network is trying to do it D correlate D
correlate the the signal yeah yes
interesting question whether what I'm
sure there's sukkah physics on that well
I one thing we do know which is kind of
interesting is that the the cones have
three different types for different
three different wavelengths selectivity
so they'll give you color vision because
you have these three different types of
cones you have we have trichromatic
vision so technically it turns out the
rods they're their wavelengths
selectivity is sitting right between the
S cone and the M cone okay so
technically when both those systems are
operating together you you're a
tetrachromatic system right you could
potentially be tetrachromatic and have
the better color vision but you don't
okay you still behave tri-chromatic alii
even though potentially you have this
fourth channel available to you so they
don't seem to interact in terms of color
vision but whether there's a precedence
effect so I don't know no no both both
signals get mixed together so so that's
it
one thing we did there both of those rod
and cone signals get they get mixed into
the same set of bipolar cells but you go
to the retinal ganglion cells so what
that time you get to a retinal ganglion
cell you don't know if the signal came
from a rod or comb it's all mixed in
okay that that's sort of that's gone
okay there are different color networks
so there's some horizontal networks that
compare l vs m and others that compare s
versus the others okay there's
density can affect the other yes the
other type that's right they're
comparing not only against neighbors but
against against different wavelengths
that's right all right along the whole
retina huge of the seat well big up okay
this is just sewing schematically a
single cord but this is really F
indicates is a single horizontal cell
and all its processes so just go back to
this diagram okay so so it'd be like us
here's here's a single horizontal cell
and then it has these processes that
extend out over the retina right so this
this single horizontal cell is processes
don't go over the entire retina but it's
connected by gap junctions to its
neighbor is connected to its neighbor so
potentially in principle that diffusion
could go over an entire retina and in
fact Fritz was telling that in Judith
Judith Hirsch who records from cells in
in lgn finds that these inhibitory
surrounds can be vast they can they can
be huge okay and this might be one way
one way one reason why okay so so that
so the thing that's really interesting
about this from a computational
perspective is that it's a much more
efficient way of computing a computer
doing this D correlation okay this is
actually implemented by Carver Mead and
Misha Mayo Wald in the analog VLSI
retina so if you think about the
traditional way this is kind of modeled
if you wanted to do this client if you
want this way most people simulate what
the retinas doing is in terms of what
they call a Mexican hat filter okay so
it's kind of just a filter little looks
like this it's positive in the center
and they give them this around okay so
it's just a filter so it just look like
the colonel and they just take a colonel
like this and they could involve up with
the image okay that's the sort of
traditional way people try to simulate
what that what the retina is doing and
that's when engineering parlance that's
that's what we call it f IR filter a
finite impulse response okay so he just
it's a weighted sum it's a neuron and
this would be its weight right and then
you have each node of different location
is sort of taking a weighted sum of the
photoreceptors through this kind of
weighting function this is a very
inefficient way of doing that because
you need wires for all these weights if
you're going to discreetly sample this
and take a weighted sum that way then
every neuron needs his own private set
of weights to the set of photoreceptor
this is a much more efficient way much
more efficient way of doing it because
the idea is you take the take the image
it's sampled by the photoreceptors here
you take this measurement from from each
photoreceptor you spread it horizontally
across the whole whole image by
diffusion and there's in the resistive
grids you model the horizontal cell
network as a resistive grid so that
diffuses the image and then you subtract
this diffused image away from the
original image okay so you take the
difference what you report is the
difference between each photo receptor
and the diffused version of it okay this
isn't much better this is a more
accurate model but the horizontal cells
are doing and it's more efficient right
it's a much more efficient way of
computing it okay doing this computation
it's release doing it through the
physics doing this low-pass filtering
through the physics of the network and
then doing this simple subtraction okay
the other neat thing about it is that
what the way this is working is this
actually feeding back on to the
photoreceptors and it's changing their
output so from the very beginning the
system is using a feedback principle in
this case negative feedback to corrupt
the signal okay it's changing it so this
signal this this photoreceptor terminal
here is not giving you a vertical
measurement of how much light is coming
in nor should it right you don't want
your photoreceptors necessarily to act
as photometers okay they're make what is
what it's giving you as a comparison and
is doing that through this negative
feedback loop from their photoreceptors
onto the horizontal cells and back to
the photoreceptors so it's actually
going back to the photoreceptor and
changing its value and that and the
output of this photoreceptor is now
reporting that difference across that
distance it's a very interesting
question I mean the dynamics of that I
was asking Franklin about this like
there are the people who've done sort of
like cable equation kind of simulations
of this and I don't know of them exactly
but there must be and this is sort of
studying the building a model that and
comparing that to the actual physiology
and of that the dynamics that spread
yeah now the photoreceptors are in the
back yes yes I'm sorry the absorption of
these cells I mean it seems like the
other way should be the other way yeah
the light is coming in this way right
okay yeah and this was like one of the
examples people give like look how
stupid biology is right they didn't do
that right sir and so every time people
come up with that argument I would
challenge you to come up with a better
way of doing it okay so the here's the
constraint the system has to work with
is that is that this thing called the
retinal pigment epithelium here what it
has to do is regenerate the photo
pigment molecules so as a rhodopsin
molecule changes this conformation then
it has to get recycled in this machinery
then it comes back in here okay if you
took the whole thing and put it that way
with this thing pointing towards the
light now this is blocking the light
this is black okay it absorbs all the
light this is a sort of tutor trance but
yeah this is not really absorbing that
much the blood vessels do they block
they block the light and in fact there
are these I don't maybe this is one here
I forget it there's a there are these
Mueller cells and Mueller cells actually
sort of act as light guides to sort of
help bring the light through and also in
the fovea if we looked at if we looked
at the same circuit in the fovea what
you would see is all these all these
neurons here in front of the
photoreceptors they're kind of pushed
aside right is there trying to push
those make sure knows about the problem
right and so it's saying look yeah I
really need you to be you know like
clear here so just get all this muck out
of the way and and make it someone
else's problem because that's okay if
it's to the side because you know deal
with it okay yeah other I almost do it
right setup and as someone else from
rich Kramer's lab was telling me that
the animals that do point on the other
way their rhodopsin molecules work in
the opposite opposite way so they don't
need an RPE okay and this is the sort of
the thing getting on our way so you
don't need that then you can point them
towards the light okay so everything
makes sense right
so don't say yes okay but but it's
really it's a lot of fascinating
questions okay so let's uh let's go on
here there's even more fun stories here
okay so then what happens to these
what happens to these to these to these
signals coming out of the cones is they
this is the cone terminal that's the
tone it's all there the signal is coming
out of the cones get relayed by book by
by bipolar cells
so for each cone you have two bipolar
cells that send its signal onto the
retinal ganglion cells okay so that
happened that's the case throughout the
entire retinas so each cone has two
bipolar cells connecting to at one of
the on type and the other of the off
type the off type has what you summary
went through to this morning the
ionotropic and the metabotropic
receptors the on type hasn't been a
tropic receptor so it's the same sign
synapse and the on type has an inverting
synapse that's a metabotropic receptor
so the same neurotransmitter here
glutamate gets interpreted two different
ways okay
by this cell it gets interpreted as an
excitatory neurotransmitter and by this
neuron here it gets interpreted as an
inhibitory neurotransmitter okay so
these signals basically this is a
nature's way of building an inverter in
K so each each photoreceptor has a
private inverter that takes the high
polarization here response to light and
converts it to depolarization okay so
for each photo stuff there there's two
signals here like Yunnan yang that are
simply going up and down in response to
changes in light intensity here all
right so so that's very interesting so
why why would you do that
why do we have two copies for every
photoreceptor we have two copies one of
the anti but here's here's they're kind
of the way to sort visualize the whole
circuit that here's the photoreceptor
here's the horizontal cells would spread
the information and and it provide the
inhibition back to the photoreceptors
and then the result of that whole
computation is picked up by these two
bipolar cells with two different signs
for to drive a dry diaper within a
single neuron okay
so cheaper is what part of my huh I
think I have an answer in the
when it gets darker the cones turn off
and rots more activated so the this is
the raw okay absolutely combined the
rods are on the on type only it turns
out so but just for the cone system but
let's just let's just say we're in the
cone regime so the rods are so daylight
regime yeah okay so car clean and
Simoncelli young car clean and you're
essentially have I think an answer and
this is a really beautiful piece of work
I'm gonna point you to because I think
it's a beautiful example where we can
use again these principles of optimality
and engineering principles to understand
maybe what's happening okay so one way
of thinking about this is that these
I'll just sort of give you intuition but
behind it initially is that is that
these is that because you're because the
horizontal cells end up computing a
different function you're comparing you
know photoreceptor at this location to
its neighbor so what's being reported is
actually a difference okay and zero
means it's the same okay if let's say
things are balanced then zero means I'm
the same as my neighbors positive means
on more than my neighbors and negative
means on less than my neighbors okay so
we're gonna get positive numbers out
we're gonna get negative numbers out and
we're getting at a zero coming out the
signals that can go down the optic nerve
are only at one sign their spikes okay
action potentials only have one sign to
them okay you can't have a negative
action potential so they can only be of
one sign so we have to take action
potentials and convey positive numbers
and negative numbers so one way to do
that is we can simply take let's just
think about here here's our our the
range of values that we could take on
here zero in the center we have positive
values here and negative values down
here okay and so what I can do is simply
bias the neuron bias the retinal
ganglion cell so that it's it puts zero
around some this is the fight we're
going to apply to hear the firing rate
the firing rate as a function of the you
know the resulting difference computed
by that filter okay so I can bias things
so maybe I'll take zero and map it to
something like fifty spikes per second
so I have some kind of spontaneous
firing rate so in you know when things
are zero I'm sitting there going Britt
or some spontaneous level and then when
things go below zero then I kind of
suppressing up and when things go above
zero I'm pretty really high firing rate
okay so I can just kind of play that
game that's one
thinking about it but that's kind of a
shame because if you look at the
histogram of activities around here what
actually comes in from natural scenes
after you do this D correlation that we
mentioned the histogram looks something
like this ok so this is the probability
distribution of values it's highly
peaked here around zero and has heavy
tails here away from zero so that's what
the probability distribution of these
values looks like just from the
statistics coming in so this is kind of
a [ __ ] thing to do right because
here's the most probable value you're
spending most the time is zero and
you're gonna be just firing away like
gangbusters all the time that doesn't
you know that's gonna way sting a lot of
effort you'll be spending a lot of gas
doing that so a more sensible thing to
do is to have two classes of neurons
take this dynamic range here and
somewhat if you know push pull
amplifiers this kind of almost a similar
kind of idea take this whole dynamic
range here and split it to two type of
different types of neurons one here it
went on here which represents the
positive part and another neuron we need
to turn on here takes the negative half
okay and if we do that now I have zero
of being represented by sort of
relatively lower in moderate firing
rates and then I use these two different
neurons to represent these two different
part these tails right so I'm dedicating
these on and off channels to
representing these tails that's what
they're showing here in this paper so
what they did is a really nice analysis
they took a bunch of natural images and
they feed them into a network so you
have a population of neurons here each
one of these points is a neuron with
some weighting function of the image and
it feeds it through some point wise
non-linearity which is also learned by
the system so they're gonna learn both
these weighting functions and these
nonlinearities okay and then there's
noise in the system so these are meant
to simulate the optic nerve fiber
outputs from the retina and so what
they're saying is well here's nature's
objective function here's what here's
what nature is trying to do is try to
maximize the mutual mutual information
it's trying to maximize the mutual
formation between the image here X and
the output are in K so these are the
responses of your retinal ganglion cells
coming out it's trying to maximize the
total information throughput through
here subject to noise in the system
there's two kinds of noise one is sensor
noise because your photoreceptors are
noisy and there's also channel noise
because these spikes coming out will
spikes at their rate codes they're noisy
they have Poisson noise
okay so this is a noisy Yorker it's
getting bombarded by noise in the optic
nerve and so you want to have a good
code which survives that okay so you
that's the one that that's one objective
is you want to maximize the mutual
formation but I'm going to charge you
I'm gonna charge you for action
potentials every time you fire I'm gonna
charge you for doing that so this is a
penalty on activity just basically an
energetic cost and saying so I want you
to have the most amount of information
subject to a penalty on firing range
okay so when you just crank the handle
on this objective function with respect
to these functions here you get out this
beautiful solution where it learns two
different populations of neurons it says
this is what I want to do what I want to
do is exactly this I don't want to have
one type of neuron I want to have two
types of neurons one of the on type and
one of the off type that says each one
of these is showing you a different
weighting function of the input okay one
of the on type in one of the off type
and you can see they're also
center-surround so at once D wants to
decore elate okay but it then it wants
to have these two different types this
is just then after learning this is the
population of Oncenter cells and this is
the population of off-center cells so
it's basically giving you kind of a way
of thinking about why why these two
populations may may have up in existence
proof of maybe a rationale rationale
behind that
they're not actually so they're slightly
different as you can see so the
off-center ones are sort of smaller than
the on center ones and that's also the
case in the in the in the biology the
off-center cells have some of the small
and they're and they're more of them
because they're smaller they have to be
packed more densely and there's slightly
more of them so Vijay Bala Subramaniam
has actually done some work on this from
a while back showing this kind of
asymmetry due to national scene
statistics so it follows that it follows
that rule - this is really really kind
of beautiful we're trying to sort of
bring bring these principles to
understand this structure in the in the
biology okay so the next part is that
after after going through the horizontal
cells and the bipolar cells then the way
they get out to the brain is to the
retinal ganglion cells they sample these
bipolar cells and in the retina I'm
sorry in the fovea and the fovea the
retina that sampling is one-to-one so
there's one retinal ganglion cell for
each [ __ ] bipolar cell so for each
cone in the fovea for each cone there's
two bipolar cells one of the on type of
when the off type and for each of those
bipolar cell there's a single retinal
ganglion cell devoted to it which is
conveying its signal to the rest of the
brain okay so that the the ratio is
actually 1 to 2 for each cone there's
two fibers coming out of the eye in the
fovea and then as you go out to the
periphery that there's more convergence
right so it's many cones feeding on to a
single retinal ganglion so yeah ok so
this is the way it kind of looked like
in the end so the reason why you have
this this fall-off in resolution with
eccentricities there's at the bottleneck
at the bottleneck does not do the cone
sampling is to the retinal ganglion cell
sampling so that's shown here in this
diagram just plotting the cone spacing
to this the average spacing between
adjacent cones as a function of xn
tricity so the cones are packed the
cones are packed most densely in the
fovea and then that density falls off
with eccentricities some okay but it's
rather modest this this is the spacing
is increasing rather modestly with
respect to the spacing between the
retinal ganglion cells so this is really
dramatic so this spacing between the
retinal ganglion cells is increasing
very rapidly as a function of X
intricity and this is why this is why
things are kind of blurred
in the periphery not because of this
okay you have lots of cones out there
and if you could have the cones
delivering the signal you would have
pretty you would have much better
resolution out there periphery so it's
being sub sampled by by the retinal
ganglion cells the way that looks like
for these two different classes the
[ __ ] [ __ ] retinal ganglion cells and
then another class called the parasol
Redmond ganglion cells as shown here so
just these are the [ __ ] and this is
really the vast majority about vast
majority of fibers in the optic nerve
are coming from your retinal from your
[ __ ] retinal ganglion cells from these
here because these are the smallest and
they're packed most densely and then
they're simply increasing on averages
just showing the dendritic field
diameter which is also proportional to
spacing increasing linearly with
eccentricity is what on the periphery
okay so so I keep one way of
interpreting this is that given the way
it's being read out you might as well
build really big cones out there you
could just write but maybe biology just
can't build really big cones I don't
know this is I started it some point you
get to just those stories but but but
but the way it's being treated they're
being based basically but you're taking
in the periphery you're taking a bunch
of cones and treating them as one really
big cone effectively okay it's not clear
I don't know if anybody's done
psychophysics Turner physiology is
showing that you actually gain something
from all these punctate sensors being
pooled together into absolutely it was
increased sensitivity but also
presumably having a really big cone
would also increase sensitivity right
you'd have a bigger cache so either
you're gonna do that catch by some
mating in one style you're gonna sum it
across cell okay so this is kind of what
that looks like when you put that
picture together there's a really nice
visualization done by Charlie Anderson
and David Venice and they were my but my
advisors at Caltech showing so it kind
of it this is actually drawn to scale
they're showing only every one one every
xx retinal ganglion cell this is for the
parvo I'm the first for the for the
[ __ ] retinal ganglion cells okay
because if we showed all the retinal
ganglion cells would just be a big black
mess okay so we're just putting that out
and we're just showing every xx retinal
ganglion cell when you're looking at an
object like our hands so just it doesn't
be like your hand you know
arms-length and then sort of be bring
your hand closer it would be this thing
here okay so every dot every dot here
corresponds to a different read of
language so and this is so it sort of
would look like and you're in your
retina the highest density here
I mean falling off this is five degrees
and then dot dot dot this is like way
over there you know outside the room
these are written getting the cells in
the periphery so they're pooling their
dendritic field size is very large and
they're pooling over over multiple cones
many comes out there in the periphery
and the spacing the spacing between
these sample nodes by the retinal
ganglion cells it follows a very lawful
relationship and the macaque monkey it's
very well fit by this equation e is the
eccentricity list the spacing as a
function of eccentricity increases with
this function electricity okay so so
what a child is that you have something
here we cause a retinal a scale
invariant sampling lattice and you'll
notice that if you just sort of look at
your hand when it's this distance away
versus when it's this distance away the
number of ganglion cells that are
subtending your fingertip is the same
okay so the only place you gain
information is you take an object you
bring it closer to you the only place
you gain information here is in the
center okay everywhere else the amount
of information about this object is
exactly the same in case what's its
scale invariant in that sense and and so
this was actually this also this this
this this functional fit goes along with
some really nice soccer physics that was
done a long time ago by Stuart Anstis
but he looked at is the the nominal
letter size the smallest letter size you
need to smallest size you may need to
make a letter in order for it to be
legible okay so this is just plotting
the just barely legible letter size as a
function of eccentricity and that's also
increasing linearly with eccentricities
so you can read letters in the periphery
just fine as long as you make them big
enough and how big you have to make them
is basically dictated by how many
retinal ganglion cells you have out
there at that particular X intricity
okay so no matter where you are you need
the same number of retinal ganglion
cells to read a letter okay if it's in
the fovea if it's five degrees out if
it's 10 degrees out of as 20 degrees out
that's what this is saying and the
number actually comes out to about about
for about for about no ganglion cells
across so any given letter needs about
four retinal ganglion cells sampling it
across to be legible this is like sort
of another kind of a chart so if this
were a good reproduction and you had
20/20 vision then when you fixate the
center here all these letters would be
equally legible and you'd be at the
psychophysical threshold so you only you
really be correct 75% of the time so it
feel frustrating but you can do it okay
this is if you do it at ten to ten times
the threshold type so all these letters
when you fixate the center here all
these letters subtend the same number
but no ganglion cells all right so this
is a really interesting design at the
retina and I think an interesting
question it begs this kind of
arrangement it's light unlike any camera
that we have every camera that we build
today that we use right and all their
devices they all have uniform sampling
you know a rectangular array and it's
uniformly sampled that's the way all our
technology is built what if you han't
what if someone handed you a camera that
was built this way right with really
fine sampling in the center and it falls
off fell off with that centricity what
would you do with it you'd move it
around okay right you'd have to move it
it wouldn't make sense it just like take
a picture with it right I mean it would
be you'd have always detail here and
then it would fall off me it's like
depends on where you look right so this
kind of strategy it goes hand in hand
with eye movements okay so this is where
the gets really interesting is how do
you build a system like this and we
don't have any systems that work this
way today right why not it's because we
don't understand something there's some
very basic sort of engineering
computational questions we don't
understand about how to do active vision
with these with it with this kind of
sampling lattice but biology does that
and it's been doing it for a long time
and probably for a very important reason
so this is you know so Jarvis was famous
for making these these measurements on
eye movements this is just showing what
it looks like when you look at this
woman's face and the places you look and
so you're moving your eye about three to
five times a second okay and you're but
for the most part unaware of these
movements you're making but your eye is
constantly in motion in fact also
showing a second there is no such thing
as a static image for the retina it's
just no such thing it does not exist
because it's always in motion even when
you think you're holding her eye still
is still moving okay so so the eye is
always in motion and the other
interesting thing about these eye
movements is that they're purposeful
right they're not just kind of like
random scanning motions of the scene you
looking at particular kinds of features
and locations in the scene and this is a
really nice experiment that Michael and
it's the same Michael van der that did
those other papers are in book I talked
about this is Michael land in his
kitchen making tea and so what he did is
he disadvantaged camera with a portable
eye tracker here and Dana Ballard and
Mary hey haven't been doing very similar
experiments at UT Austin sort of looking
at where are you looking and natural
scenes and in the sort of natural tasks
and so here he is watching what his eyes
are doing as he's making tea
today well so we'll just watch this
video here and hopefully come up on
YouTube here oops
okay so he's so this is his eye down
here so you can see how his eye as
moving around in the scene and then the
dot here the white dot shows where he's
looking in the scene so here's the
boiler there's a cup and then he just
sort of going around the kitchen and the
eye is moving all over the place
okay and so if you were doing this task
yourself you wouldn't be aware you're
doin doing this right you just say oh
I'm making tea and but your eye is just
moving all over the place and again it's
not just sort of random is scanning is
moving in a very purposeful way to guide
to guide action okay it's looking at the
scenes that you things that you want to
grab how you want to pour the tea how
you want to pour the tea and so forth so
Dana asked this question this morning
about interrogating right he's talked
about like v2 is asking a question about
about the image or about the world or
something like this and this is one way
of thinking what I move Mazar doing when
you measure i'm movements like this this
is the brain interrogating the world
right you're sort of able to see
something about this unconscious process
in your brain and how it's interrogating
things in the world during during a very
natural task okay so they're sort of
doing all kinds of sophisticated things
to do just like an everyday task so it's
a really interesting question of how how
you do that another eye tracking maybe I
guess okay all right so that's so that's
the other so there's another aspect of
these eye movements which is that is
that even even when you're trying to
hold your eyes still they're still
drifting there's these micro saccade
that occur during fixation they're a
combination of drift and in small
corrective microseconds but mostly
mostly drift and this is just showing
that this was measured in Austin Reuters
lab who is right over there in miner
Hall so each one of these dots is a cone
and what he's able to do is look inside
your eye and see how your eye is moving
the whole cone array as you fixate this
object here so you went a subject in
this experiment you can look at that I
hate you can read it and it looks still
it looks stable to you it doesn't appear
like it's moving okay looks stable to
you that this is the raw image coming
into into your retina and so this is
even so you're just trying to hold your
eyes still in this case not these kind
of saccade looking like we're on the
scene so why is the system doing this
right is this a feature or a bug is that
just that you know biology sloppy and
can't kind of hold the camera very still
or is this a good thing how many people
think is a good thing
many people think there's a bug okay
y'all know where it's going right so
you're a computer scientist so so it's
so it so it turns out so Austin and
Kavita Ratnam's student in rosten's lab
did some really nice suck of physics
with this and show that it actually
helps you okay so what they did the way
they way they do that is compare the
natural condition where the e is
drifting with natural movement across
across the retina they look at your
ability to do this task as a tumbling a
task where this e is and one of four
different orientations so the
psychophysics is looking at your ability
to discriminate which orientation that E
is in and under these different
conditions and so when you have this
natural motion versus stabilize so
because of tracking the the retina they
can actually stabilize this obvious so
it's completely stabilized on the retina
over time of course it eventually fades
but that's after about a second okay so
it takes about a second to face so
obviously once a fade you're gonna do
worse but you don't have to worry about
fading here because there's all less
than the interval for which over which
the information it fades away okay so
what they the first thing they showed
here is that it's actually you know you
do you have better performance when it
moves them stabilizing does not help you
it actually hurts you but even
introducing artificial motions so now
because they're tracking everything in
real time they can introduce artificial
motion of their own choosing which is
incongruent with the eyes natural motion
so even if it's incongruent are
artificial motion of that with the same
statistics as natural motion it also
helps you so this these effects here are
I'm statistically I'm significant you do
as well but it actually infinite but it
actually is a little better I guess but
it's definitely better than the orange
bars here and so yeah about the way
ganglion cells wants to respond they
respond better to moving
so that you could explain why the state
why is the incongruity of Morse oh it's
better so it's it's it's helping you
yeah it's it's it's better than the
orange and it's even better than the
eyes a little better than the eyes
natural eye movement okay that's that
I'm getting so at the point that first
point is the eye likes to move right it
doesn't you know we might think oh you
should get that thing stabilized fix it
right know it likes to move and why does
it why does it like to move well we have
a story about that this is Alexandra
since June in my lab and his work and so
here's here's a simulation of this and
so what we're thinking is that because
when you're at these very high acuity
limit when you're when you when you have
just barely enough photoreceptors to
sample the object you right at the right
at the Nyquist limit then you're sort of
subject to the inhomogeneities in the
red small sampling lattice so say the
cones are not sitting there on a perfect
rectangular array there's all sort of a
regular spacing between them they have
different games they have noise there's
different types LNM and so if you
stabilize that image then the appearance
of this object would change depending on
which cones you happen to land on what
their offsets were what their gains were
it was sort of change its appearance as
it moves as it lands on different ones
so one way to do with this is you just
move it across the array and you average
his appearance over these different
photoreceptors it's not unlike what
people do in super-resolution okay so
that's what we're proposing and this is
a model of how that might work so what
output did is put together a model
showing how a population of court two
neurons in cortex could take this
information coming from the retina and
read it out and do this averaging in the
right way to kind of get this super
resolution this is just a simulation of
it here yeah
it's not necessarily about light
it's about irregularity because you have
an imperfect camera okay it's not you
that you're so much that your light
starved but the so but but I would
predict that if I engineered your
Countians better you would do that less
maybe but I don't know that that's been
well studied but yeah related to the
spacing the amount of motion you mean
the drift if you make it too much then
it's not yet at some point at which
that's gonna hurt you
right because you don't you can't
compensate so the idea is that as this
as this R as this object drifts across
the retina this is just showing the
averaging of its appearance okay so if
you just took one measurement if I just
show you a single snapshot of that at
the beginning I'll just start it over
again just start it over again so just
because you get a really sort of crappy
image of it initially and over time if
we just let it drift and average his
appearance while compensating for its
motion so with but the system has to do
is actually estimate the motion
simultaneously with the pattern okay so
it's doing like a slam kind of algorithm
to do that okay so as the spikes and
this is what is doing with this these
are the on cells these off cells coming
I'll just do that one more time these
are the on cell spikes these are cell
spikes and so what is doing a saying
okay there's an e in there and has to
build up the image of an e internally
from this data okay so it has two
simultaneously estimate the motion and
then compensate for that motion to do
the averaging the correct way to build
up that appearance yeah creating a phase
locked image and so if you knew whoever
was going
that you could very quickly build up
your picture that's yeah if you if you
know where it's going then that's right
that's in this case what did I do a bad
I haven't thought about phase locking
how that would fit into it though his
picture on the salamander retina shows
that early spikes are they accurate okay
very cool so we so we're not putting any
of that kind of that's right okay so
like the Tim collars kind of studies
we're sort of assuming these are stupid
stupid retinal ganglion cells that have
rate codes so if we put more intelligent
kind of spike timing more precise spike
timing and see how that would affect it
I think that would be that would be
definitely something yeah right okay
so yeah it just means that it's it's not
the eyes own motion so here's it's uh
it's what we do is we just take other
measurements of motion just artificial
motion that has the same average speed
and extent and it's otherwise random
right so it's not it doesn't have to be
the self generated motion it's just
saying basically any kind of motion not
any I mean it has to be in the right
range that's too fast if it's too big
and what's not going to help you but if
ya know I'm sure in darkness that does
that that I can't vouch for that bad I'd
bet you a lot of money is still doing
this in something you can't control you
can't you can't say hey I stopped
drifting I mean it just it's doing that
all the time that's the most common
stories if you ask people well why do
the eyes move like this they'll say well
because if you don't the eye the image
will fade but the image fades because
your photoreceptors and in the retinal
ganglion cells have a have a AC response
character so they filter out the DC but
that's kind of circular region because
that would just say well why does it do
that so the point is that there you know
this is this I think this is
kind of moral reasoning yeah it is it's
a say it's basically the same idea
super-resolution now I'm not it's not
gonna give you it's not super resolution
in the sense that you're exceeding what
you already have it says you're amazing
making the best use out of it you're
getting like the max out of it okay but
you can't pretend yeah if you did even
if you really under the right
circumstances if you maybe sort of
didn't have as much noise or something
or yeah potentially that's right similar
sort of joint estimation going on with
the controls on the focal distance of
the length or not that I know of yeah
presumably you see this also in low keys
absolutely yeah drifting into micro well
okay so that's interesting so it's it's
it's at some point we only get this
benefit when you're right at the Nyquist
rate right right limit okay so so if you
made this II somewhat bigger then it's
not gonna be like a big help anymore
okay
I think that's happening everywhere I
think this is a universal cert principle
it's a special case of it here but we
were just talking with Jeff Hawkins and
folks in his group they're sort of
thinking about it the touch system but
this is like a microcosm of the same
thing that it like the rat whisking
system it has to do the same thing right
it has sort of two tickets owned with
whisking motions and Bill dynamically
build up some kind of sense of the world
so I think to me this is kind of like a
little tiny case study of that general
idea that's the way I think of it
okay I want to go in and talk about
bigger things so so so Marie already
took us through a lot of the the
core-tex but there's a few things I just
want to kind of highlight and one is to
me what's one of the most amazing things
this is just kind of showing that some
of the main players here the retina the
LGN as Marie explained relays in French
of the cortex all this is cortex up here
v1 the primary visual cortex here this
is thalamus and here the two major parts
that Marie talked about the LG and the
pulvinar and then down here the midbrain
is superior colliculus and the superior
colliculus is involved in controlling
eye movements all right so that so the
OP not just eye but also head movements
say the reflexive orienting when
somebody for something flashes your eyes
and your head kind of move over there
that comes from this structure here okay
so these are some of the main players
but one of the most intriguing aspects
of this wiring diagram are these strong
feedback that these strong feedback
loops in the system okay so this
information pathway from retina to LGN
is one way but this pathway here there's
a one going from LG ohm which is rolling
information the cortex but there are
many more fibers coming back from cortex
to LG on Somer a sort of cautioned us
against counting things but nevertheless
you know the fact that they're more it's
like wow you know there's that's kind of
attic space right so why do you need
that high numerosity okay
it doesn't necessarily say they're more
important but still there's sort of a
lot of hardware that's being devoted to
doing that and what's that doing again
comparing it to engineering we don't
build computer vision systems that way
in all of our modern vision systems
information goes from the camera to the
computer we're thinking about here a
computer which has has more wires going
back into the camera and it's actually
going in and changing the information
that the camera is sending you okay so
without this feedback way pathway you
could say that the LGN was relying the
image to cortex but what is doing is
relaying a corrupted image to cortex
this this pathway here it's modified by
what the cortex thinks okay this is the
world this is data about the world
coming in and this is what you think is
going on in the world right this stuff
is intermixed together so what the LGN
says the cortex is now corrupted or
modified okay how does that work how do
you make that productive right in
engineering principles unknown we don't
have any good theory we don't have any
good models of what
that is doing none at all okay in our
field right now yeah it's all the
information from LG and being given to a
v1 like all the input that is get is it
or is it transferred into v1 let's see
how would you answer that Korea in a
monkey coño cells project outside of the
yeah that's like the main conduit and in
other animals like cats like this would
be area 18 the cat then it goes kind of
both to area 17 and 18
okay but in primate and monkey it sort
of goes mainly to v1 and then and then
to get to v2 in aus to go from v1 using
a corrupted Ted yeah anyways no yes
I wish I knew that that's what I'm
telling you guys about this I have this
whole point if there's I wanted sort of
plant interesting questions and why
would you do this yeah you can imagine I
could go there are fibers to go back
into the eye they change the focus the
lens right
there's fibers that go back in here and
they change the iris right depending on
the light right these are wires they're
not going back into the retina in birds
they do in birds that you go back into
the retina in us they go back here okay
and they modify the image of their why
because if you want to look at something
where's my favorite textbook yes hi in
the cortex is very abstract so the
spatial information is and in from the
temporal cortex is so washed away and
mostly at the feet Allisyn centric
features and so whether it has a
computer vision sorry okay what I want
to do is go down in the image and do
this maybe do template magic okay okay
it's all that information where where
where I used to do the template matching
it's in the LGN yes so that's why you
wanna watch okay then
then you should build a model you should
build a computer assess a vision system
that works that way alright somebody
right okay I mean my point is that if
that's a good idea then we should have
real systems that work that way right
but yeah that's the way the brain works
and get away with that
all right there we have lots of theories
like that in our field right we have all
these kind of these are sort of like
what's the you know like sitting your
couch and doing computational
neuroscience just by thinking a lot must
be the reason okay all right so we want
to do better than that right he makes
similar arguments that these these tests
are done early early in the visual
system and any of tons of tons of
evidence that it's kind of happening and
people like Johnny Gilbert
I'd say them kind of you're it's not
like we could we have a computer vision
listing but we have we have just a lot
of ancillary every this kind of view is
I love all that I love all that I love
the model you just initially stated
there but I guess the point is to take
that and now implement it in concrete
terms because until we do that we don't
have I don't think our field can claim
that we have a good explanation of what
you know what this is doing well they're
they're both they go they they project
on to the relay cells and they also
project on to the inhibitory in what
sense we psycho physically people say
you don't see most of the things out
there right
in the periphery that allows us work oh
I see then we're not aware of everything
in the scene so this is you know Francis
Crick and Christophe cook had a paper
years ago where they sort of had us the
spotlight spotlight attention model of
what this thing is doing right and so
that was kind of like their ideas I turn
its attention so this sort of gold yet
cortex it goes down and turns up the
gain on different parts of the LGN where
it sort of wants to attend on the scene
things like that again it's a hand wavy
model what I'm asking is like is like we
need some kind of utility to demonstrate
here in computational terms and that's
what I think the field has yet to
accomplish so okay so the yeah there's
some obvious things that should be fixed
like the blood vessels yeah do we know
like where does this get fixed in the
cortex
there's a couple different ways of
thinking about the blood vessels one is
that you you know you're born with them
they've always been there and you kind
of just calibrate to them and in fact if
you bring in light from the side so if
you can you can kind of shine light in
from aside from an usual angle so now
the blood vessels cast a shadow and the
photoreceptors and the way you've never
seen before they light up like crazy and
it's actually scary to see them because
it's just like this very intricate web
of you know stuff across like other boys
they come from a and it's right there
it's all the time and but that's one
that's one way people think about it and
it's another reason for maybe why you
want to move things like in the fovea
you know why you want to kind of move
things around
so okay so the so just going on to the
cortex here so the the primary visual so
the Murray talked about all these
different areas in the visual cortex
this is the primary visual cortex here
which I want to say a few things about
the fovea is represented here so there's
a topographic representation of the
image across across the surface of v1
the fovea is here as you go across this
out here you're going along the
horizontal Meridian this is the vertical
Meridian being mapped here and if you
just take this v1 so the v1 fold goes
around on the other side and kind of
they're all unfolded on the calcarine
sulcus here the other side so if you
take that and flatten it out you'll see
something like this this is just a map
of visual space on the surface of v1 so
here's the fovea being represented out
to 2.5 degrees X intricity here here's
the center of the fovea right it has 5
degrees 10 degrees and you'll notice
greater amounts of visual space are
being just shrunk into a small amount of
cortex you basically have a logarithmic
compression of space onto the surface of
the cortex and of course this is going
to change is you I just mentioned before
you're moving your eye like three to
five times a second okay so this is it
introduces kind of a conundrum and that
the image is going to change in four
interesting way so here's just a very
creative visualization of what that
looks like as you're looking at Homer
Simpson and sort of where you're looking
and the scene gets magnified greatly and
the reason why of course is because you
have more retinal ganglion cells there
so there's therefore more cortex devoted
to that and you have fewer retinal
ganglion cells out here so that's kind
of all getting compressed and shrunk
into the cortex okay so there's the
scene gets or shrunk out here so this is
kinda this is how it comes in this is
what's happening in your visual cortex
as you look around the scene here's a
question should you be disturbed by that
about that
you know so kevin O'Regan who's gonna be
visiting here in April will say well
this is not a problem at all I think
it's a problem maybe there's something
we have to deal with the Kevin or Ricans
argument is this is not a problem at all
to get disturbed about this that's like
getting disturbed about the fact that
the image on your retina is upside down
or it's upside down listen the BAP site
in the cortex so somehow you have to
kind of re you know make it up right
right so this is just like a different
reformatting of the signal that it's
kind of all stretched out like this so
you know it's just something you kind of
have to calibrate to and you've learned
through experience how to interpret this
kind of information but I think there's
there's and yeah I think there's a lot
of truth to that argument but there's a
there's a greater problem that gets
introduced here is really how do you
take these series of fixations as you
move around the scene this the series of
fixation as you look around the scene
and how do you build that up and
consolidate it into one model of that
object okay your experience of the
person here when you do this is not like
all these distorted things you have one
consolidated model of what that thing is
and that lives in memories sticks around
you can close your eyes and ask I can
ask you questions about it and you'll
know things about the places you've
fixated and all that information somehow
gets registered together in one unified
consolidated model that's the problem
that needs to be solved okay somehow is
and other people refer to this as the
stable world problem how do you
experience a stable world despite the
fact that the eye is always moving
around like this okay
and again our field does not have a good
answer to that it does not have any
answer to that question how would the
computational basis of that how do you
utilize this kind of strategy
effectively and how to neurons
[Music]
ah this discontinuity here because this
is like the left hemisphere that's the
right hemisphere yeah and they're so
like they're sort of totally split up in
different hemispheres depending on you
know right across where you fixate you
think some however years ago wolf singer
showing something about binding you can
sort of show how features are kind of
when they're sort of lie across the
horizontal Rhydian I made the vertical
Meridian when they have to go through
the corpus callosum to get integrated
that something happens differently and I
forget exactly what it was but there
might so yeah I don't have exact answer
where's a great question yeah there's a
question over here in visual circuitry
does information start getting shared
between the two eyes the first place
that happens is the is in the cortex
that's where the two eyes come together
and they start to combined into a common
set of neurons but up until that point
like in the LGN they're segregated into
different layers and also in layer four
there Mason mainly in different parts of
layer four but by the time you get to
the superficial layers of v1 now you
have these binocular neurons that are
combining the left and right eyes and
we're stereo is done okay so I just want
to case it may be let's see okay like
just plug on here and talk about
receptive fields and a little bit about
the sparse coding the sparse coding
model so one one interesting finding
about about these neurons in v1 the
primary visual cortex is that the
receptive fields are orientation
selective and that makes them very
different than the neurons in the retina
and in the in the retina and the LGN
which are just the center surround
circularly symmetric okay so this is
kind of a new property the merges in the
cortex and the way people have sort of
thought about this as a way of giving
you feature selectivity okay so that
what the cortex is trying to do is
extract features about about the visual
world and so Barlow sort of thought
about this the idea a long time ago and
came up with this back in 1972 proposed
this theory of sparse coding and it's
simply the idea that what maybe the
cortex is trying to do as opposed to
other regions right maybe think about
like what the retina and the LGN is
doing in terms of that model of
Simoncelli is trying to simply deliver
information it simply has a delivery
problem okay it's trying to take all
this information that's captured from
this photo sensor right that nature went
to a huge extent to do very efficiently
in single photon detection all that take
it and efficiently send it to the brain
and let the brain now figure it out
okay but now the brain doesn't have to
do compression and delivery anymore it
needs to do interpretation of some kind
okay so how do you how do you think
about that and so one thing he thinks
what if this is something that's
different that's happening in the cortex
you're trying to take this information
that's coming in and reformat it into a
new form where it's expressed and
represented in terms of a small fraction
of active neurons in the populations you
have this large population of neurons
this is representing it you don't have
to go through a bottleneck it's a very
large population of neurons that's
representing it and you want to try to
express that in terms of the smallest
fraction of active units on this
population okay so one idea is just a
way of gift coming up with a compact
representation of the scene and this
theory was really kind of inspired by
things he just observed in cortex
okay activities of neurons tend to get
more silent another is just from the
anatomy when you look at what's these
how things are wired up these neurons
coming in these so these are the LGN
this is just showing a to scale a
visualization of the LGN afferents
coming in and these are the neurons in
the recipient layer of layer 4 4 see
where they were they where they deliver
their inputs okay so each of these
circles here denotes a neuron this is in
cross-section so you have the same
picture here coming out of the board
okay so as you can see here this is
maybe one way of sort of think about
this conceptually is like in the first
layer of your neural network okay so you
have many more neurons here then you
have pixels coming in here okay and so
what Horace Barlow kind of conjectured
is that you're taking this very over
complete population and using it to kind
of carve up carve up the space and make
these neurons more more selective do it
through a sparse code yeah
what does it stand for oh the lateral
geniculate nucleus it could have been
anything right you could call it XYZ but
uh yeah it's uh okay so the one so one
way bassoon we try to take Marlowe's
ideas this is work I did with David feel
though a long time ago is to express it
in terms of linear terms of mono let's
say but the cortex is trying to do
here's the image data coming in let's
try and describe that image data in
terms of a small number of active units
in terms of some basis so it has some
basis from basis set for describing the
image data coming in and these a sub
eyes would correspond to the activities
of neurons in the cortex okay so if I
put a sparsity cost into a penalty on
the activity of these units then we
could see what kind of functions emerge
here and if you do that the basis
functions that are learned just from
natural seen statistics resemble these
oriented functions of visual neurons
okay so that gives us one way of
thinking about why why we see this this
cut these kinds of properties in the
cortex and not other places that are
maybe more concerned with just simply
delivering information because here in
the cortex you have the real estate you
have the number of neurons needed to
make an over complete sparse code of
image data okay so it's one way of
thinking about how these orientation
cells selective cells come about as in
terms of a efficient coding strategy
this map map to map to map to national
scenes
so if you can check that model that I
wrote out we can make an objective
function for it which expresses
basically two things the desire to
minimize reconstruction error which is
kind of like the mutual formation term
in the Kirkland Simonelli model and a
penalty on activity and when you
minimize that objective function do
gradient descent on that with respect to
the basis functions then the learning
rule that comes out is very similar to
like a heavy and learning rule it's just
like a local learning rule between the
image coming in and the sparse sparse
activations in the cortex and Jules oppa
Burke and Mike Deleasa forked out some
more by a physically plausible model of
how that could happen all right so I
think one let's see it maybe there's two
things I want to leave you with before
we finished so I'll just try to get the
in thing he's pretty rapidly so there's
this kind of standard model of a v1 that
is the that has emerged in terms of
neurons just having receptive fields and
and taking taking the information that
they get from the receptive fields and
putting it through some kind of point
wise non-linearity and the way many
people think about what v1 is doing now
is in terms of like a Gabor filter bank
that just has this array of filters to
which which is kind of representing the
image and and and then feeding that on
to the next area sort of like this is
like the the first layer of your neural
network and about 10 years ago or so
David field and I sort of realized you
know there's a lot there's a lot of
problems with this model and then I
think this is one of things I really
want to sort of convey to this audience
and if you open a sort of a textbook
you'll see this picture the picture I
just showed previously and that's the
way sort of we people kind of
conceptually think about what v1 is
doing and and so I think we we sort of
think there's a there's a lot more going
on then then we are currently currently
thinking about and this is one way sort
of picturing that and when reason why is
just due to biases and sampling using
single unit physiology stability and
recording techniques when you put
electrode into the cortex you're kind of
trying to sample from some
representative population to
characterize what's there but you're
kind of going on a fishing expedition
and you know how do you know that we
really sort of characterized all the all
the cells that are there and for the
cell that you have characterized the
question is how well do your models fit
what we're finding is that even though
these models actually fit pretty well
with gratings sometimes when you put
natural movies on dynamic natural
stimuli the models just start to fall
apart you can try to rescue them by
adding various correction terms and
things like that but it's nothing like
the original model that you started out
with right so this is starting to feel
like you know there's something really
kind of then just like pieces of the
puzzle that just don't fit with this
kind of standard story that we sort of
passed on now from one generation to the
next about v1 is doing and and so
there's there's a sort of a lot of
mysteries there so I'll just leave you
this with this one which is that if you
if you sort of look at how many how many
neurons are in a square millimeter of
cortex so this car made of cortex is
where you have like a full
representation of all these different
orientations and left and right eye
there's a hundred thousand neurons in
that amount of cortex now if you look at
how many LGN neurons are coming into
that same amount of cortex it's
equivalent to about a 14 by 14 about a
14 by 14 image the 14 by 14 pixel image
okay no matter where you are okay so
it's a little more many maxy
it's a it'd be fewer in the in the fovea
okay but outside of the fovea it's about
a 14 by 14 pixel image so this is just
like the visualization that's that's
what a hundred-thousand looks like this
is a hundred thousand people in a
stadium okay so we have to sort of think
about if you claim to have a good model
of what v1 is doing you need to account
for why it is that you need this many
neurons representing a 14 by 14 pixel
array of the image and again I would
claim our our field does not have an
answer to that question the standard
model does not answer that there's a
huge disconnect you don't need that many
neurons in this model right nothing like
that okay so what's it doing there's
something huge that we're missing here
there's a huge explanatory gap between
not just the physiology but also the
anatomy and all these things we see and
the standard story we keep on
passing around do we know the circuit if
you will up those extra they're all in
those different layers that Murray
talked about this canonical you know
that basically many of them are layer
for this this highly over complete
representation you have in layer four
and the input layer but in layer two
three is the whole whole gamut you know
and what that's all doing yeah this
mystery switch emerge from recent
simultaneous recordings from lots of
neurons pause and retina and even like
my parish showed know that you have this
population events rather than having
this fine every neroon report something
not which is almost optimal you have
this really clumsy population events
then it does occur spontaneously and
according to rock I just and others and
also Mike Harris new data also in the
run you have this clumsy and a
population coding right rather than this
very fine optimized local coding well
why would they not be clumsy is yeah
it's not apparently Owen doesn't report
anything to have this kind of assembly
events its assembly yeah if you assembly
events there's nothing to see right so
from the perspective of computation is
one of the Versa codes that you could
know think of okay I don't know III
think it's a that's I think we I get
what I'm saying what we want is a
quantitative model that takes all those
ideas right and quantitatively says look
I need a hundred thousand neurons and
this is what this is what they're all
doing and this is the kind of
information they're conveying and the
process ignore doing it says what layer
five is doing this is what layer two
three is doing and this is how they're
conveying that information to other
areas and that's what we're missing is
that level of explanation
of course it's a great question but if
you go back to Marie's lecture all these
buses are coming out of the cortex and
presumably they have a function and then
so the you're gonna pay a price a
building a network to compute what the
answer to that function and then send it
so that basically it could be that the
simple cells of the tip of the iceberg
and when you have to sort of code that
for the in from the various other
regions that needed then you pay a price
of building a little specialized
serpent's circuit from every little bus
coming up so that's gonna that's right
persistence of vision what was Eddie
that's what I was gonna try to get up
with this diagram here so maybe just
I'll just mention it real quickly but
this is the this is the this is a
submarine memory showed that diagram of
a visual cortex the hierarchical kind of
structure of the cortex all these
different sort of boxes and this is
another reason of that map of the
venison fellowman wiring diagram where
they redrew these boxes now according to
the size of those areas okay so the size
of each these boxes represents how much
cortical area is devoted to each of
those and these these these these are
the busses between the areas right the
size of those representing how many
wires are going between them okay so one
thing is is really really
thought-provoking I think when you look
at this diagram is you know where does
visual experience reside where is the
persistent this sort of stable world
kind of percept that we that we build up
so everything we know from the
neurophysiology tells that that these
are being replaced every time you move
your eyes and this is a huge amount just
like v1 and v2 alone v2 is even bigger
than v1 but this is patooties alone this
is a huge amount of cortical real-estate
being devoted to these right and every
time you move your eyes everything we
know tells us that's completely being
replaced what was there is just being
replaced by something else
so maybe persistence just rise up here
but then it's a very compact
representation
of this of this sort of persistence
stable world but we don't see there's no
sort of like world world scene buffer
that we can see in the brain kind of
being built up and so I mean I think
that's that's it so that's an
interesting question that's evolved by
this this diagram yeah concrete I kind
of movement also had in that in order to
be another system to compensate by
movements does it all over yes so the
more thing is I'm going to mentioned so
the another thing the pulvinar is doing
when one of the big inputs the pulvinar
is the superior colliculus and that's
making eye movements right so every time
you make an eye movement there's a Ferns
copies of that being sent to to the
cortex and this is on and that theory of
I had another diagram of it Thank You
Larry Sherman theory of about the lira
when the layer of five neurons project
to super colliculus they have a branch
which goes into thalamus and that gets
relate back to the cortex so there's
lots of signals coming into the cortex
telling it how the eyes are moving but
again how are those kind of things
getting mixed together so one way of
thinking about it that is that these
representations while they're fleeting
right but also your visual experience is
fleeting right when you look around the
world at the time you're looking at
something you see all kinds of detail
about it right you could reach out you
can grab that object you can do all
kinds of things with it when you're
looking at it the minute you move it's
gone all that detail you still remember
some things about it some things stick
but the things that stick are much
cruder right maybe something more
abstract up here it's a much more
abstract representation as it sticks
around but all the details are gone
right and so so I think there's you know
oftentimes the main downside when we
look at that in the venison fellowman
wiring diagram this is the venison
Feldman diagram this is a you know also
kind of provocative when it you know a
verse first came out and what I thinks
about it is like it's sort of kind of
suggest that like this is the input this
is the retina the image data coming in
down here and that's the output if
that's the top box that's the
hippocampus right and you know so that's
kind of a what is it and this is kind of
intrinsic and deep learning like deep
network thinking right is that this is
like a multi-layer neural network and
you put images in here and objects come
out
right and that's just obviously you know
no I mean and so so so Murray Sherman
and Ray Guillory have this other way of
thinking about it I'll come and have to
skip the cow sorry okay Murray Sherman
regular I have this other way of
thinking about it which is this is kind
of like the the stupid model I just
mentioned you know but the image data
comes in that goes all the way up to the
top box and then the top box the
executive says okay yeah there's an
apple there go reach it and do something
with it right and what they're saying is
no that's not that's not the way it
works is that all these different
cortical areas v1 v2 these very rich
detailed representations you have the
seen which are fleeting but nevertheless
in very which they're there and that
huge buffer of cortex right they have
something to say about what you should
do right they're part of your a visual
experience they have something to say
and so the layer 5 neurons in all of
these areas in v1 and v2 in before an
ITA all these areas they have something
to say about what you should be doing a
mate and these they are five neurons
essentially can be interpreted as motor
outputs and they in turn drop these
these afferents into the thalamus which
then feed back at the cortex so another
way of thinking about this thing is a
sickness is basically a hierarchy of
nested sensory motor loops okay so you
have various sort of low level loops
down here as sort of mid-level loops up
here and higher level loops up here okay
and so when they you know when Maurice
Sherman actually came to Davis years ago
and when I was first a faculty member
there and gave this talk about his wacky
idea of you know that their information
is going between areas through the
thalamus because I came from deep in fun
essence lab and it was like of course
it's going from v1 to v2 right and so
how dare you think about it that way
this bizarre this has really been
eye-opening we have no idea if it's true
there's some evidence for it right but
it's really a radically different way of
viewing what the cortex is doing and
frankly to me it makes a lot more sense
than just sort of like you have you know
going to the top box and down so there's
a lot more a lot more evidence in sort
of in various ways
oh boy okay so just maybe one minute on
this tree I'll just say one thing real
quick about it the big mystery here is
other animals and I mentioned just like
like and you know how other animals use
the visual systems and this is just one
of the best examples out there I think
also an animal that was intensely
studied by Michael Van tear UC Berkeley
in the 1960s the jumping spider it has
eight eyes it it has these two
forward-looking eyes which have very
high resolution it sees the world by
moving its head it moves its eyes it
does all kinds of things that does prey
capture does an object recognition it
can do navigation in three dimensions it
does path planning so when you put the
de spider - and and have it push the
ship situation where has to go get a
prey item it doesn't simply just lurch
at it and sits there and surveys the
environment and then finds a path it
climbs down the pole goes around will go
to the 3d gym and finds the object ok
just these amazing things this is the
mystery ok so we've been talking about
the core attacks these things they're
mammals and the things they do alright
it's all done here great it is all done
here in this nervous system that has
less than a million neurons ok it's a
tiny tiny tiny tiny nervous system and
it does all these amazing things we're
doing about it so I'm talking about it
does motion at those tracking it does
object recognition it does is these
wonderful dancers you know - it's for
courtship displays this defies
scientific explanation we have no idea
how to think about this even I don't ok
and it's just it's it's really sort of
an amazing thing to think about and
again it just makes me think that we're
kind of sometimes asking the wrong
questions and I'll just near Shiv each
started out his started out his talk
with up with a poem and was something
somewhat poetic by it live right Rob
Brooks and this is another way he has of
thinking about he says problem-solving
behavior language expert knowledge and
application and reason in other words
the thing is we're always sort of
talking about an AI building programs
that do play go and chess and all these
things right they're all pretty simple
once the essence of being and reacting
are available that essence is the
ability to move around in a dynamic
environment sensing the surroundings to
a degree sufficient to achieve
the necessary maintenance of life and
reproduction this part of intelligence
is where evolution is concentrated it's
time it's much harder it took evolution
a long time to build a jumping spider
okay
a jumping spider does and that's heard
like the core the core set of algorithms
that that visual systems can do and once
you had that okay when the cortex came
on the scene it evolved extremely
rapidly it just exploded and all this
stuff happened in a very short amount of
time and so maybe the kinds of problems
were thinking about like object
recognition oh how do you do that and
you know we sort of get kind of obsessed
with these things and maybe those aren't
the core problems these the the core
problems are just like standing up and
not falling down right and just kind of
having kind of stable behaviors and
working in a real three-dimensional
environment doing things that jumping
spiders do is think doing things that
bees do and I think I sort of feel like
there's a lot to be learned there that
we should be thinking about as
computational as computational people
all right so I think that we've been
taking questions but I think that's it
but thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
one question it begs is you know if you
can do all that in that tiny amount of
real estate then what do you need a
cortex for of course well we can we can
build a Simon's Institute and sort of
you know write equations on the board
and all these things but so I don't have
the answer you know it's just I think
it's really important thing to think
about you don't have to have a cortex to
do vision you can do huge amounts of
vision without a cortex without gigantic
V ones without thalamus without all the
stuff that we're familiar with and and
how those animals are doing that they've
solved a core provisions that we don't
even know how to describe at this point
what the problem is I think you know how
properly formulated and write it down
and let alone solve it but if we could I
think we'd be in a much better starting
point to understand what the cortex is
doing they are now
[Applause]